so i used to go back and play with the
guys in the summer every night again and
jimmy
you know he was a hustle man he was kind
of you know guy who defend knocked down
some corner threes but
i really think none of jimmy liked that
and so the draft comes
and jimmy get drafted 30th pick and i
say wow
good for jimmy like good for jimmy he
made it in the nba didn't think he was
gonna be that good
and then first couple years in chicago
my guy's on the bench i see him over
there with that weak fro and i'm like
they got my guy jimmy
but jimmy don't talk to me because
thibodeaux didn't like the heat so jimmy
never talked to me
no i see jimmy out in l.a i don't know
if jimmy remembered i seen jimmy jimmy
out of l.a at like one of the parties
like for like
sp weekend whatever the case may be and
jimmy don't speak to me
at all i'm like dang that's that was my
okay whatever
he choked he changed he changed on me so
it goes from me saying damn good for
jimmy to me having to call jimmy at some
point
later on in my career say hey man can i
come to chicago can i play
we was taught to hate y'all man and hate
everything about the miami heat
and i understand why y'all used to beat
our ass
on a regular basis it was like
damn near disrespect was like how you
just disrespected me throughout that
whole story about how it wasn't good
[Laughter]
it was blatantly disrespectful the way
it used to beat up on us in chicago man
yeah
i mean if the rules are reversed you
would hate me too you would
shaq nope you hate me
i don't have any more questions i just
want to know how yeah
that's what you said i don't give a damn
what you talking about that's what you
said who has a better hang
that's what the hell you said ah okay i
have another question right jimmy i was
gonna yeah i was good
he did he did say that thank you that's
what you said we're gonna roll the tape
we're gonna check and i'm sure your
hands were better go for it again
recording this so you could change it
you could like say something else and
they could
you know you're right i'll dub it up
this was something like we made we made
this game we might play
oh we want to play a game yeah colin d
wade had another question no don't worry
about it go ahead
we good man move on okay well i wanted
to you guys to rate jimmy butler singing
this song in the locker room
but give it a one out of ten can we hear
it jimmy we found an old clip yeah let's
take a listen hold jimmy in the locker
room
[Applause]
[Music]
i need to stay off my instagram
oh that's easy i get out of nine
yeah you would
jimmy does does dwayne complain i'm
gonna give him a 10. the feet work was
nice the rhythm was nice he even put his
shirt on
in the middle of it yeah in the middle
of it so i'm gonna give you a change
jimmy boy
jimmy did dwayne complain to you as much
about people being upset with the dunk
contest nine that he does to us
did he confide in you he's like why is
there on being hard on me
nah okay cause truthfully i really don't
think that he cares like
i mean it is what it is dj that man he
can't get no 10 if he didn't clear the
man
i'm with you on this d-wave